love love love this film uh first big
question admittedly might be overly
prescribed and not the way you approach
a role like this but when you're
preparing to play Bella what is the very
first piece of her that you find the
thing that confirms to you you're on the
right track but then I also want to know
the last thing you found the thing that
convinced you like yes I understand this
person and her journey as a whole oh wow
that's a good question and really
difficult because she is a flawed and
experimenting person obviously as she
says the actual performance of it felt
that way too like it felt very
experimental as as we went along I mean
we came up with with stages of Bella's
development whether it was her
physicality or the way that she's
speaking but really A lot of it was like
on the day through it those things were
were shifting and developing and so you
know there's so many different parts of
Bella throughout the whole story because
of of that you know kind of expansion
and and journey that she's going on that
it's it's hard to nail down what that
what it was I mean I understand that
that's part of the reason why I asked
the question I can't even begin to wrap
my head around every element that makes
up her entire Journey but leaning into
what you were just saying I I have a
feeling this will touch on that a little
bit because so much of her journey is is
her reacting and learning from how other
people treat her so can you name a time
when a scene partner gave you just what
you needed and maybe helped you find
something in her that you wouldn't have
been able to without them oh my God all
all the the actors in This filmer
incredible and when you know joros we
had this rehearsal process for three
weeks before we started filming and
so it was it it's very silly and freeing
and you know crazy our rehearsals on on
Yos movies and so by the end of that
process you feel really close to each
other and like you have no embarrassment
around each other you're just like
playing so much that it it leads to an
environment where in any scene that we
were doing together whether I was with
Willam or with Romy or with Mark or you
know I mean so many of these incredible
actors it felt very you know like
supportive and kind of cozy to be with
them um so and and that's my favorite
part about being actor is is other
actors you know like I love getting to
have those those moments with with other
actors and um who you're who you're
working with is like everything um so
yeah this was a this was a lucky break
on this one with these people I'm gonna
end with a with a personal career
question inspired by Bella's Journey
because one thing I absolutely loved is
how alive she is because she sees
nothing wrong in things that Society
deems wrong so as an actor what is
something about the approach to acting
that you thought was wrong because of
what others had told you but then you
realized it wasn't wrong and because of
that you were able to be more free with
your craft I
think
I have always tried to sort of you know
there's there's only so much choice you
can make as an actor especially at
different points in your career but when
you get to make choices of like what you
want to work on and who you want to work
with and all of that I think I don't
ever think from the outside in like I
don't think about like what people would
expect of me or something um and I think
I in the past I think I remember like
you know that that concept of like make
one for you and one for them that kind
of thing and I don't believe that at all
I actually think the more you feel feel
like it is a story that you you really
want to tell or be a part of or or
something you want to make I actually
think that's much more resonant to
people that are watching it rather than
like I'm doing this for you guys that's
a weird concept to me so that I guess
keep making bold choices for you and
supporting other bold films as a
producer problemist I'll just shout that
one out another top-notch film right
there oh I'm so glad on that than
congratulations poor things I look
forward to celebrating it for many weeks
and months to come thank you so much
good to talk to
you